part of the reason why you guys have 24
seasons now under your belt is because
you do show the UPS you do show the the
Downs you show families that hey we're
on camera and you know it's not all
happy all the time everyone's met Josiah
but we don't have plans for Karen
Demetrios I like they still think they
did nothing wrong Zach and Tori have
really isolated themselves you know from
me and Cha-Cha like we are a normal
family we fight like a family we love
like a family but at the end of the day
we are a family and heading into this
new season what would you say how would
you describe it I know it might be a
complex question how would you describe
the
status of the relationship of the Roloff
family right now I would say the status
of the relationship I've had to
summarize is it's going it's on the
right path it's on the working we've had
some setbacks uh you know in recent
years we shared all those on the on the
upcoming season and and before
um but you know it's it's all our real
life is always a little bit ahead of
when things are released so we are you
know we're definitely working I'm
talking to Zach every day we're planning
my dad's memorial so the whole family is
really involved in that um on a you know
very active basis it's not easy but it's
going in the right direction I would say
and I we you know don't have big
expectations every single person I ever
talk to I'm always curious does your
family have stuff going on and lo and
behold everyone does Karen tells other
people that she's waiting for our Olive
Branch and that Olive Branch the dove
took it to another Island I don't know
well here we are season 24 of the show
when you hear that 24 seasons could you
ever have imagined having cameras around
this long
now not we can never we would have never
met we did not imagine it it just sort
of snuck up on us you know it's amazing
how time flies yeah I mean with that
being said too I I how long do you want
to keep the cameras around when will you
know it's time to literally shut them
off yeah well we take that kind of kind
of day by day or week by week or you
know month by month so we just sort of
take that one step at a time but uh you
know every uh every year we kind of
reevaluate where we're at and if we have
more more you know positive things to
share and that would just kind of take
it as it goes yeah well speaking of
positive things to share of course we
have another season you know it's always
kind of interesting when the season gets
free to come out you know in one minute
we're excited and we can't wait to see
how they put everything together and the
next minute you're scared to death
you're hiding under the bed you know
hoping that you know you didn't make a
fool of yourself on TV but you know
we're sharing our true family Story the
UPS the down and just about you know to
kind of related to your last question
just about the time we say oh man we
can't do this anymore it's too
embarrassing it's too it's too hard
um then somebody comes up to us you know
in the public and we'll say you know how
touched they are and how their family's
going through some of the same stuff you
know the same hard stuff that's really
hard so it makes it a little harder to
share your hard stuff you know in the
public eye and you get a lot of comments
about that but you know we've learned
for the many years that we've been doing
it
um that the the in the balance it's you
know it's good it's really showing
people that we're just a normal family
we have certain challenges and uh but
we're going we're working through the
ups and downs you know and hope other
families are doing the same what can we
expect especially in terms of drama
because I know there's a lot of tension
well you know our show is always kind of
been a relationship based show so it
shows the different relationships and
how they interact and we spend a lot of
time with Chris and Amy
um continuing to develop our our
relationship with them and we Lila's
birthday you know there's birthdays
involved and that we're all there what
else can we remember I I don't know we
film it and then we forget yeah and
there's you know of course there's
always the drama piece and they you know
we'll have the family get along not get
along the house going up for sale we're
hopeful that another season doesn't go
by where there's still Strife but we're
just kind of waiting it is tough too
because like hearing you guys try to
figure out okay when was this filmed
what was the state of our relationship
then where we are now it's two different
things and then you're reliving it when
the episodes air which is tough because
like when I was watching when I was like
hmm I wonder if the relationship is
still like this with the tension and
it's not things have changed as you said
you talked to Zach you know daily now
and so is that hard for you to relive
the episodes as they air and then see
these conversations kind of come back
with new life on social media all that
or do tune it out do not it's a
combination of both we we it is hard to
relive them it aggravates the situation
sometimes again but uh but and then you
know but then we do tune it out a lot of
times we don't we watch a preview and
then we kind of tune it out you know so
it's sort of accounts you more tuning
things out than uh anything stay on
social media stay off this and you know
and just know that the more there's Buzz
I'm talking about and people are you
know slamming me or slamming somebody or
Karen you know it's uh it's well people
are interested you know my dad used to
say something very wise to me he said
would say when I would come home crying
from school and say Dad at school the
kids tease me because I was sure work
they go to one with Matt at least
they're paying attention to you there's
a lot of lonely people out there that
have to wear dye their hair purple and
put on bright pink tennis shoes to get
attention from people and so at least
you're getting attention may not be
right but let's figure out how to take
that attention and make it positive and
so that's been a mantra in my life you
know that you know we're not lonely you
know Karen and I are together we have a
wonderful family we love all of our kids
dearly yeah there you go
yeah I'll do this
[Music]
this needs to be a little bigger so you
can actually drink coffee out of it okay
wasn't there a movie about this
will we see more of your guys's
relationship evolve in the new season
I don't know what do you think
we couldn't tell you
Karen and I are still very very close we
love our Arizona plates we travel down
there to help my mother and her folks
are down there and we just got back late
last night from a little quick little
getaway and we have some exciting
vacations planned together but as far as
anything else you just have to wait and
see okay so can I ask like do you two
talk about the next step in your
relationship all the time okay do you
guys talk about where you see yourselves
down the road long term I'm gonna say
the N word do you talk about marriage
yeah we do we do yeah and then we um we
have a plan that when all the stars
align just right we will both know it so
we're trying not to feel pressured but
we're totally committed to each other
and we do we we talk about our one year
plan our two-year plan our Five-Year
Plan so you're starting to sound like
our executive producer
when you said we're like we're trying
not to be pressured I'm like so ladies
stop asking us these questions no I I
you two have built such a beautiful
relationship and I'm so happy that you
found each other and and thank you
oh God love is the best it is when you
find your best friend like everything
changes and it's just exactly right it's
so fun to go through life the highs the
lows to have
a partner to have a teammate and you
guys are very blessed to have found each
other to be able to do like one of a
kind right here I landed I mean it's
very very amazing
[Music]